okay so what's the difference between
springing Boo and corcus well for
building microservices and Cloud native
applications Java is a popular choice
and today we're going to look at two
Java Frameworks we're going to look at
their differences compare them and look
at them through the angle of performance
developer experience and ecosystem so
let's go ahead and hop right in and
start talking about spring boot so what
is spring boot Well Spring boot is
what's known as a opinionated framework
for creating Standalone and production
ready uh spring applications and what
spring boot does exceptionally well is
it gets rid of a lot of boilerplate code
When developing Java applications and it
comes with a vast ecosystem that makes
it a go-to for many developers now
that's spring boot but let's also talk
about corcus because corus is a newer
Java framework but it takes a different
approach now corkus is made for
delivering uh container optimized and
Cloud native applications that have a
faster boot time and better resource
utilization it also combines both the
imperative and reactive programming
models and has a lot of tools for
developer productivity now where do we
even begin with comparing spring Boot
and corcus well let's take a look at
their different use cases because spring
boot is generally used to speed up the
time to market for working with Java
applications and then corcus on the
other hand is made for optimized cloud
ready images uh and applications as well
now let's go a little bit deeper because
both of these can compile applications
using both the jvm which is like running
our apps through an interpreter and
natively which is compiling an
application for a specific machine and
it has a lot of performance benefits but
speaking of performance I want to go one
step further and talk about arguably the
biggest difference between spring Boot
and corus so this relies in the
differences between build time and
runtime so I'll use a different color to
to to map out corus but let's start off
with spring Boot and look at the build
time so during the build time this is
the packaging of the app application
using perhaps a tool like Maven to get
the application ready and then during
runtime different tasks are happening so
we're working with configuration files
we're working with scanning for class
pass and initializing components and
this is happening every time that we
start our application and what corus
does is it kind of flips this on its
head and tries to do as much
pre-processing as possible so this
results uh during the build time and the
packaging of our application and all the
other tasks and then when we actually to
run our application we have what's known
as a pre-warmed image that has a faster
boot time and better resource
utilization okay so that was performance
but now let's take a look at developer
experience as it goes hand inhand with
the speed and the cost of software
development now we'll start off with
spring Boot and what it does very well
is it abstracts a lot of the complexity
of building out a Java application this
is because of things such as its
popularity with auto configuration uh
uses of n annotations things like code
constructs and if you're already
familiar with spring boo it can be very
fast to get an application up and
running now corus also brings in some
great components in what's known as
corus's uh developer joy and so what
this developer Joy really includes is a
bunch of different components such as
live coding and continual testing
integrated by default the corcus
developer UI which is a great way to
visualize your dependencies
documentation things like Swagger and
also the CLI for interacting with our
projects from the command line so they
both offer their unique advantages when
it comes to a development experience but
let's also talk about the ecosystem for
both of them now we'll start off with uh
spring boot again which originally was
created in 2014 and has since become the
de facto standard for building
Enterprise Joba applications and because
of this it has a quite a large community
uh and documentation and resources for
building applications with spring Boot
and debugging now on on the other hand
corcus was created in 2019 and has been
rising in popularity ever since this is
partially due to the popularization of
kubernetes as a container orchestration
system and because of its extensibility
with over 800 different extensions that
you can use for your projects Okay so
we've taken a look at these different
perspectives how do you really pick
which one to use for your project well
let's start off with quirkus because if
you're working with serverless or
containerized applications with minimal
re resource consumption corcus is
probably going to be your best bet
corcus has a highly active Community a
lot of up-to-date and comprehensive
documentation and growing support from a
lot of leading tech companies who have
adopted corcus now if you're looking for
a mature framework with a vast ecosystem
then spring boot will probably be your
best bet spring boot is welln it's very
well adopted and it's a complete and
Universal solution for any task right
out of the box but listen both of these
Frameworks have their advantages it's
all about picking the right tool for
your specific needs and as Java
continues to evolve we're going to see
spring Boot corcus and other Frameworks
continue to innovate and make our lives
as developers even easier now I highly
recommend that you go to the quick
starts for Spring Boot and corcus to get
started with a project on your system
and figure out which one is right for
you I want to thank you so much for
watching this video feel free to like it
if you've gotten some type of value out
of it and feel free to subscribe to the
channel